what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and lately the MCU has
been announcing really great things as
far as the future of the MCU is
concerned Marvel's Phase 5 has been
completely revealed and phase six is
looking pretty good with the projects
announced being the Fantastic Four two
Avengers films Avengers the King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars and now of
course Deadpool 3. this was all revealed
to us in the past few months which has
been completely awesome but what was
truly awesome was how Ryan Reynolds told
the world that Hugh Jackman was going to
be returning as Wolverine and how both
of them were now going to be in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but we did
have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
to top it all off on top of that teaser
Hugh Jackman actually came on screen
with him again talking about kind of
what to expect from Deadpool 3. hi hi
how are you you have questions yes I I
add a lot of questions I'm sure you had
a lot of questions but rest assured
we're going to answer them right now
like for example how is Wolverine alive
yeah after Logan Logan takes place in
2029 totally separate thing Logan died
in Logan not touching that
but what if I told you that Wolverine
was already going to come back for
Deadpool 3 even if Deadpool was still
going to be a fox movie and the Disney
Fox still never actually happened and
that this was actually a part of Ryan
reynolds's plan the entire time you see
as it turns out we could already know
the plot for Deadpool 3 and what the
main story is going to be about Ryan
Reynolds has been working on the script
for years and it sounds like it's going
to be pretty dang epic you see Deadpool
3 has been in the works for many many
years now because remember Ryan Reynolds
had planned on doing a Deadpool 3 over
at Fox before the Disney foxtail got
done so Ryan Reynolds has been working
on the script for years now and all
evidence points to the fact that Ryan
Reynolds has had a general idea for the
movie done for some time now and it
always featured Hugh Jackman as the
Wolverine and not just a tiny Cameo or a
gag about Wolverine but the entire story
sintering around the relationship
between Deadpool and Wolverine now based
off of what we know if this is done
properly and I have no doubt that it
will be it could be the craziest
funniest and most brilliant multiversal
story lines that we've gotten so far in
fact Deadpool 3 could lead us to seeing
almost every Fox Marvel character back
on screen and then killed in true
multiversal fashion I'm looking at you
the Illuminati
but we are also probably going to see
Deadpool and Wolverine go to many
different universes in a sort of buddy
cop type of movie which I'm all here for
you see Ryan Reynolds kind of already
revealed the plot for Deadpool 3 some
time ago almost just about two years ago
Ryan Reynolds tweeted on January 28th of
2021 this it's critical to have open
honest and healthy discussions around
mental health by retweeting Bell let's
talk you can make a difference in case
that's not enough before Disney bought
Fox Deadpool 3 was gonna be a road trip
between Deadpool and Logan rashamon
style for real and this is actually
brilliant for those who have seen
rashamon or know what it's about you
know that Deadpool 3 could be set up to
be something truly amazing if it's
copying some type of rashem and style
it'll be funny and as Hugh Jackman and
Ryan Reynolds have already told us it's
going to be full of action and probably
pretty bloody and don't worry I'll
explain exactly what rashmon is in the
the plot for Deadpool 3 and why Ryan
Reynolds is a genius and speaking of
Ryan Reynolds big thank you to Mint
mobile for sponsoring this video most
people know about mint mobile because of
Ryan Reynolds but most people don't know
about mint Mobile's amazing quality and
I have to say there's an extremely good
reason that Ryan Reynolds is pushing
mint mobile so much because it actually
is a great phone company mint mobile
sent me a free plan and at first I
didn't think too much of it I have one
of the major Wireless providers however
I don't get that good of service with my
provider and over the past three months
I've got an incredible service with mint
mobile to the point to where if I
actually need to make a phone call I
will use my mint mobile phone and what's
crazy is their plan is so much cheaper
mint mobile offers Wireless for just 15
bucks a month they give you the best
rate whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plan so everyone gets the amount of data
that's right for them and you can use
your own phone and keep your same number
and contacts so to get your new Wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month including
the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic now rashamon is a
1950 psychological Thriller it is the
story of A Murder of a samurai retold by
various people all of which have a
slightly different perspective on how
the crime took place so imagine this
scenario Deadpool kills the fox Universe
before going to the MCU and maybe not
just the fox universe but other
universes as well we'll get to that in
just a bit but imagine Ryan and Hugh
kill the fox universe and then they have
different perspectives on how and why it
happened the banter between them would
probably be fantastic Deadpool would
have probably initiated everything and
started a big fight and started the
killing rampage that could be how Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine saw it but on the
other hand Deadpool could say well they
started it they came at me they are the
reason we had to kill them it wasn't my
fault you can imagine how this could be
pretty dang good now since Ryan Reynolds
talked about Wolverine and Deadpool
going on a road trip together we have to
kind of wonder where exactly would they
be going well since Deadpool 3 is going
to be based in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we can imagine the road trip
starts in the fox universe but ends up
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
possibly some stops in between in other
universes this is going to be a
multiversal road trip because we already
know they're going to end up in a
different universe but we also know that
Deadpool did some time travel and at the
end of Deadpool 2 doing what he called
cleaning up the timeline he did a lot of
killing then so we could probably assume
that that's what's going to happen in
Deadpool 3 as well now like I mentioned
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman have
already teased a lot of action so could
this mean that we are indeed going to
see the death of the fox Universe this
is something that Deadpool could
certainly do and probably only Deadpool
no other movie show or character could
get away with killing an entire universe
of old Marvel characters breaking the
fourth wall and essentially calling it
what it is the end of one Universe with
a few survivors like Deadpool and
Wolverine and remember that just because
Deadpool 3 will take place in the MCU
doesn't mean that it has to be in the
MCU the entire time it's most likely
going to start in the fox universe and
end up in the MCU what happens in
between is going to be that road trip
the road trip of Deadpool and Wolverine
killing a lot of people most likely with
both Deadpool and Wolverine each having
kind of a different perspective rashmon
style of how and why the killing went
down so it looks like we have the basic
outline for Deadpool 3. Ryan Reynolds
revealed this almost two years ago and
if you take into mind Ryan Reynolds has
been writing the script in entire time
and the original writers for Deadpool 3
Rhett race and Paul wernick are back on
board with Deadpool 3. the script is
probably sticking true to what the two
of them and Ryan Reynolds have been
coming up with over these years Marvel
Studios originally wanted the Molino
sisters to draft a new script however
the original writers for Deadpool 1 2
and 3 were quickly brought back on board
so this seems to be our story for
Deadpool 3 a road trip with Deadpool and
Wolverine involving time travel
multiversal travel and a lot of killing
which will ultimately end with Deadpool
and Wolverine in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to me this sounds awesome you
can kind of do two different stories
here you could do Deadpool kills the fox
universe and you can do an awesome
multiversal road trip with two of the
most iconic Marvel characters there are
I'm all here for it but let me know what
you all think about this in the comments
down below would you have it any other
way let me know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest MCU news for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]